so und ich freue mich wirklich sehr
jetzt eine frau zu begrüßen die
regelmäßig genau solche fanpost kriegt
herzlich willkommen petra gerster halt
schön dass sie da sind gerade erst
verabschiedet von den heute -nachrichten
schon in der heute show so schnell
kann's gehen
sagen sie mal wie handhaben sie das wenn
sie solche gender liebesbriefe kriegen
wie solche die wir gerade gehört haben
antworten sie darauf also auf die also
auf die höflichen also zumindest der
form nach möglichen briefe antwort gibt
es natürlich ja gibt sogar viele weil
unser unser publikum wenn der heute ist
ja doch ein älteres und sage mal gutes
publikum und die schreiben also schöne
altmodische analoge briefe ich bin ja
auch nicht in sozialen netzwerken aber
auch weniger e-mails eben daran sehe ich
auch dass es eben viele ältere sind und
viele ältere männer vor allem ältere
herren die 90 prozent ablehnen schreiben
und fehler auch also emeritierte
professoren darunter männer mit
doktortiteln die mir erstmal seiten
lange erklären was der unterschied
zwischen genuss und 6 ist und was ist
mit dem generischen maskulinem aus ich
habe genau ich habe viel gelernt
immerhin richtig immerhin hat das netz
ihnen noch auf den letzten metern ihrer
heute karriere einen eigenen hashtag
geschenkt und zwar den hashtag gender
terroristen
sie sind quasi der osama bin laden des
zdf sie wirken wenn ich das sagen darf
so harmlos erklären dass man genau wie
genau sind sie in die gender terrorismus
zähne reingerutscht wie ich da
reingerutscht bin ja schwer zu sagen
ich glaube ich habe also ich habe mich
eigentlich mein ganzes leben lang schon
irgendwie mit sendern im weitesten sinne
befasst also mit mit rechten von frauen
und gleichberechtigung insofern kommt
man zwangsläufig dann auch auf das
sprachproblem hat mich aber selber lange
dagegen gesperrt weil ich dachte es ist
irgendwie bisschen schwierig zu sprechen
und habe aber es in der letzten zeit
festgestellt dass es gar nicht der fall
ist und ich habe jetzt auch so 345 durch
die gender der bücher gelesen von
jüngeren frauen und hat festgestellt man
gewöhnt sich sehr dran und es ist es ist
eine ausdrucksform die unserer
veränderten gesellschaft jetzt
entspricht jetzt wird diese sendung hier
in
köln produziert wie läuft das in mainz
wo er einige kollegen beim zdf ländern
und andere nicht wie wird jetzt so viel
auf die nicht gender druck ausgeübt
gibt's da erst mal so als bewahrung und
dann dann schneidet einem irgendwie
claus kleber die reifen durch wie genau
aber jetzt wird sofort abgeschaltet
nein das ist das schöne wir arbeiten
beide oder ich nicht mehr jetzt bei
einem liberalen sender der überhaupt
keine vorgaben macht das glaubt keiner
mehr glaubt uns kein mensch glaubt dass
ja auch niemand dass frau merkel nicht
morgens mir irgendwelche direktiven gibt
bei den nachrichten oder gab
nein wir haben ja viele leute bücher
zurückgeschickt 3 mit dem tenor seit sie
mit ihrem sender waren uns terrorisieren
wie sie eben sagten oder seit sie die
sprache goethes und schillers der art
der derart gewalt antun können wir ihre
bücher auch nicht mehr weiter als sie
die deutsche sprache genau aber der
vierte hat er mir zurück geschickt wegen
der korona lügen die mir die
bundeskanzlerin offensichtlich jeden
morgen einfach als vorgabe gehabt für
den nachrichten genannt werden also es
gibt also dann haben sie dann auch
manchmal verständnis für leute die sagen
sie fühlen sich vor allem in den
nachrichten so es aber irgendwie belehrt
oder erzogen wenn sie da manchmal folgen
also wir machen das also ich mache ich
bin ja eine der wenigen das ist ja
überhaupt gar keine mehrheit die gent
hat sondern sie eine minderheit
und das fand ich eben auch an unserem
sender wirklich schön dass er so liberal
war zu sagen dass wir trauen unseren
journalistinnen zu mit ihrem
handwerkszeug der sprache verantwortlich
umzugehen und sorgfältig und insofern
allein an der tatsache dass eben manche
zu ändern und viele nicht denn dann
sieht man schon dass es keine direktive
gibt und auch kein putsch von oben und
kann schon gar keinen putsch von unten
sondern jeder und jede macht ist so wie
es für richtig hält
am siedeln sich eine erklärung
zurechtgelegt warum diese debatte so
wahnsinnig emotional geführt wird
ja mir kommt es so vor als als machen
haben einige leute das gender thema
wirklich als neues thema entdeckt an dem
sie irgendwie alles fest machen können
was ihnen sowieso schon seit langem
nicht passt also ein immer bunteres
deutschland immer selbstbewusstere
frauen aufmüpfige minderheiten die sich
lautstark zu wort melden
das führt natürlich ängste und vor allem
bei älteren die sich so kommt mir das
vorher noch ihnen noch nach ihrem 50er
und 60er jahre deutschland zurück sehen
in dem sie aufgewachsen sind wo alles
noch sehr überschaubar und geordnet war
aber das gibt es halt nicht mehr das
alte weiße männlich beherrschte gucken
sich in der unterarm als männlich weiß
stimmt also ich meine ja das gibt es
halt nicht mehr und das ist passé und
aber natürlich lässt sich mit dem thema
und deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt
gerade so virulent letztlich natürlich
super gut wahlkampf machen mit den
ängsten vor dem diesem neuen deutschland
und das nutzt die afg weidlich aus aber
auch cdu politiker wie friedrich merz
zum beispiel absolut aber es gibt
übrigens auch andere cdu-politiker das
möchte noch schnell dazu sagen wie der
saarländische ministerpräsident tobias
hans der einsender freund ist und
erklärt wenn sie vor einer gruppe von
zum beispiel jungen studierenden der
medizinischen fakultäten stehen und das
sind 90 prozent frauen dann dann merken
sie und sie benutzen nur die männliche
form also dann merken sie dass es schon
reichlich schräg und unpassend ist und
dann geht ihnen ein licht auf haben sie
denn das gefühl diese debatte wird am
ende zu irgendwas konstruktiven führen
also sie im moment trägt sie scheinbar
ja noch zu mehr spaltung bei wenn man
die reaktionen sich ankommt wird das
irgendwie ein konstruktives ende dem was
glauben sie ja also wir sind im moment
in so einer probephase also alles die
ganze gesellschaft verändert sich rasend
schnell zur zeit und aber die diskussion
eben wie wir zu einer
diskriminierungsfreien und gerechteren
gesellschaft kommen die app nicht ab
aber natürlich wird sprache allein jetzt
nicht die diskriminierungen vermeiden
oder verhindern helfen oder abbauen
helfen das wäre naiv zu glauben aber sie
kann zumindest auf der bewusstseinsebene
etwas auslösen und insofern langfristig
wirken
und wenn sie mich fragen ob es sich
durchsetzt ändern also die jüngeren sind
aufgeschlossen ich bekomme ja auch kost
zustimmende posten auch sehr nette post
von newron übrigens auch jungen männern
die eben dem gendern zustimmen und ich
denke bin die zukunft nicht
meiner generation also die werden das
entscheiden und zwar ganz demokratisch
und sie werden jetzt wo sie nicht mal
beim sex denn weiter bücher schreiben in
dem sicheren wissen dass ihnen die
gender gegner diese bücher dann wieder
zurückschicken
das passt das passiert die regelmäßig ja
dann kann ich dir weiterverschenken ist
sehr praktisch also ja gerne wieder
zurück so ist noch nicht genau abzusehen
die zuschauer
petra gerster das neues buch warum es
gar keine strafe für mich ist wenn man
meine bücher zurück schickt weil man hat
sie ja schon bezahlt vielen dank petra
gerster dass sie da waren ja
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebsten
mit ms wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]